اكتوبر من عام 2022
بخفض الانتاج بمعدل مليوني برميل يوميا
امريكا اعلنت معرضتها للخطوه والسعوديه
مضت قدما فيها اتهامات للرياض بالوقوف في
صف بوتين وتهديدات امريكيه بمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه
وبينما كانت الولايات المتحده تراجع
علاقتها مع السعوديه كما تقول مضت المملكه
في طريق مصالحها الامنيه والاقتصاديه رؤيه
2030 للامير محمد بن سلمان تطلبت استقرارا
سياسيا السعوديه وايران اتفقتا على اعاده
العلاقات بوساطه الصين الرغبه في استقرار
سياسي بالمنطقه يقود الى نماء اقتصادي
وتامين خطوط امداداتها الى العالم
الصحيفه بوليتيكولا الامريكيه كشفت انه
وبعد مضي سته اشهر من التصريحات لمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه لم يحدث شيء وان
حديث بايدن عن العواقب كان سببه فقط
الشعور بالحرج من خطوه اوبك بلس الصحيفه
اكدت ان اداره بايدن لا تستطيع الاستغناء
عن السعوديه وانها لم تجري اي مباحثات
جديه لمراجعه العلاقات معتبره ان زياره
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه غير
المعلنه للرياض جاءت في سياق استعاده
العلاقات القويه مع السعوديه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات